The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
JOCELYN: Hi.
Jocelyn here and today we're
going to go over fall 2009
exam three problem
number four.
Starting with part A--
let's read the problem.
In the 1920s, Jack Breitbart of
Revlon laboratories found
that acne could be treated by
the use of benzoyl peroxide.
The oxygen-oxygen bond in
peroxide is weak and under the
influence of modest heating,
benzoyl peroxide readily
decompose to form free radicals
according to the
reaction given.
The rate of decomposition is
measured at 92 degrees C at
various concentrations
and found to be--
and you're given two different
concentrations and two
different rates.
So part A asks, determine the
order of reaction for the
decomposition of benzoyl
peroxide.
The first thing to do is, when
asked for the order of the
decomposition reaction, we
want to think about the
general rate loss, right?
We're given concentrations.
We're given rates.
We're asked for the order.
Something you might want to
have written down on your
equation sheet or look up is the
general rate law equation.
Remember that students taking
these exams did have an
equation sheet so they could
have this ready.
The important part is that
you know when to use this
equation, what each
of the terms mean.
So r is the rate.
k is a rate constant.
It is a function of temperature,
but if you're at
the same temperature, that rate
constant will not change.
It's constant.
c is your concentration.
And n is your reaction order.
So this would be the place to
start for this question.
And now we know that we're
solving for n.
So what is n in this case?
Looking at what we're
given, we can write
two different equations.
The first line gives us a
specific rate for a specific
concentration.
The second line gives us another
rate for a second
concentration.
So now we have two equations
and two unknowns.
That means we can solve for one
of the unknowns and then
could solve for the other one
if we wanted to, but here we
only care about n.
So how I'm going to choose to
solve this and you may choose
to do it differently--
I'm going to divide the first
line by the second line and I
get rate one over rate two
equals c1 divided by c2 all to
the n power.
So that made the k drop out,
which is one of the unknowns
that I don't care about because
the problem isn't
asking for that.
Now all we need to do
is solve for n.
So if we remember algebra, we're
going to take the log of
both sides.
Because of the properties
of the log, we can
bring the n out front.
So n equals--
and plugging in the numbers
given in the problem--
they're given in the same
units so everything will
cancel out and that's good--
we get that the n equals one.
So this is a first
order reaction.
Now you could've probably done
that by inspection if you're
familiar with the rate law and
how to determine that by just
seeing that as the concentration
went down by a
fourth, the rate also went
down by a fourth.
However, the question asks for
you to determine the order of
reaction and so we were
looking for more of a
derivation of the problem
instead of just an inspection
because that shows that you have
a familiarity with the
general rate law equation.
So now moving to part B--
we are asked, on the plot below,
sketch the variation in
energy with extent of reaction
for the decomposition of
benzoyl peroxide.
Assume that the ratio of
activation energy to--
delta e, which is the energy
of the reaction--
equals -2.5.
Label the energy states and
label the delta e of reaction,
the activation energy for the
forward reaction and the
activation energy for the
backward reaction.
So that's asking
us to do a lot.
So first we're going to write
down, what are we actually
asked to do?
So the main thing is that we're
asked for the variation
in energy with the extent
of reaction.
So as the reaction progresses,
what's the
energy of the molecule?
The energy state that
it's going through?
In that plot, we're asked to
label the energy states of the
reactant and product and
we're asked to label
the delta e of reaction.
So what's the net change in
energy as well as the
activation, both forward
and backward?
I would always write this to
the side or scrap piece of
paper or something because this
is a lot of things to put
on one plot and this will be a
nice reference to help us to
make sure we answered all the
things the question is asking.
So on the plot given, which I'll
reproduce here, it has
axes of extent of reaction
and energy.
The first thing to do would be
to label the beginning and
start energy states.
So because we know at
92 degrees C, this--
the benzoyl peroxide--
decomposes readily, we can
assume that there's
a decrease in energy.
So we'll have our products
start at a
higher energy than our--
sorry-- our reactant
start at a higher
energy than our products.
And because the question asks us
to label that, we're going
to put in the actual labels.
And so that's your reactant
and then we
have the radical product.
Now that we have our beginning
and end energy states, we need
to think about what's happening
in the middle.
A clue is that he talks about
the activation energy, right?
And we know that most processes
that we talk about
have a certain activation
energy.
You can't just go straight
from the
molecule to the radical.
You have to have a little
bit of energy cuffed.
And so we know we're going to
have some type of hill that we
have to go over.
Furthermore, in the problem he
states that the activation
energy divided by the
delta e is -2.5.
So we know that because this
is a negative delta e--
so this is our delta e here
and it's negative--
our activation energy is two and
a half times as large as
that net change in energy.
So we want to kind of just
eyeball that in here.
You didn't have to be exact,
but relatively--
it's going to be larger
than twice the
distance between here.
And remember that activation
energy is the hill, the energy
costs that you have to go
through to get to your lower
energy state in the
product size.
So now that we have all of our
energy states, we want to draw
a smooth curve to show
the variation of
energy with the reaction.
So connecting all these points,
we get two valleys and
a hill, right?
We have two stable energy
states and we have an
activated complex corresponding
to the
activation energy there.
So we have our energy diagram,
but we need to go back to what
the question is asking and see
that we've labeled the energy
states, we've labeled the delta
e of reaction, but we
need to label both
the forward and
backwards activation energy.
And this is one of the things
people had issues with--
the backward activation.
So forward activation
is pretty self
explanatory, right?
It's the energy we need to
overcome the activation of
this process and so this is
the Ea of the forward.
Now the activation energy of the
backward reaction is just
the same concept, but
going backwards.
So if we started down here, what
is the energy we need to
get over this activation
barrier?
And so that's this full energy,
this full amount of
energy here.
And so we can see that it's
bigger than the activation
energy for the forward
reaction by the
delta e of the reaction.
So going back to our checklist
here, we've answered all over
the questions and so we
can move to part C.
So part C asks us, on the
same plot above--
which we have over here
to the right--
sketch the variation in energy
with extent of reaction for
the decomposition of benzoyl
peroxide under the influence
of a catalyst.
So with a catalyst--
first to answer this question,
we need to know what a
catalyst does.
And in class, we learned that
a catalyst will lower the
activation barrier, thus
allowing for the reaction to
proceed faster.
You don't necessarily get more
product because that's
governed by a different set of
laws, but you do get the
product faster.
And so the way we can change
this is that instead of having
our activation barrier up there,
we can say it's going
to be somewhere here.
It's going to be lowered by the
presence of the catalyst.
So we want to make a smooth
curve again and connect this
lower activation barrier.
And you'd want to label this--
I'll label it in white--
this is the catalyzed
curve there.
As long as you've showed that
the activation barrier was
lowered by the presence of
a catalyst, that's fine.
That was what the question
was asking for.
So we've labeled everything,
answered all the questions and
we're done with this problem.